well let's talk about uh let's talk
about what happened in with kyle now to
contrast these two stories
so you were actually on the ground right
there when all this went down with
written house
what do you think was it was it
self-defense it was 100 percent
self-defense
uh but but let me let me let me
challenge you yeah they say that uh he
wasn't legally allowed to
carry a weapon so are you saying do you
do you believe that it was legally not
self-defense because he was illegally
carrying or do you believe it's still
self-defense
i would say like just as a human being
yeah like
he was there defending himself defending
himself right
regardless of who says this or what's
written or anything like that
they were trying to kill him they were
trying to murder him right
see but the context of that story why
were they trying to murder him the
context right what elijah told you guys
the other night is 100
accurate right they tried lighting a
dumpster on fire they were pushing it
towards the gas station pushing it
towards cops
but a good samaritan put the fire out
right
they ruined the arsonist's party i've
seen that video and they were triggered
they went ballistic that's where you see
uh
uh the pedophile right um get all crazy
and start saying shoot me
shoot me getting in like yeah saying the
n-word getting in the face of dudes with
semi-automatic rifles right so so
at the gas station yeah yeah that so
both guys who got shot the skateboard
dude yep he was there too
and the pedo guy were both there yelling
at these armed kids
yes so that was that was after they put
the fire out yes
directly after not like 20 minutes after
like 20 seconds after it just
they went directly to the gas station
and that's what triggered them and they
went ballistic because they couldn't
light fires
do you think they were trying to blow up
a gas station i don't know
i don't know it appeared to be so but i
think the context
of what this really is is they were
trying to light things on fire
okay so this is what correlates what
happened at the dealership
right because after they couldn't do
anything at the gas station
they went ballistic they set their eyes
on the car source dealership
and they were chanting i have it on
video you hear them chanting we're in
route to car source
and route to car source burn it down
burning time
i was following them to the to the get
to the car dealership
we all went in that direction and i
think kyle went that direction
too because he was going to defend
because at that at that time
tim it was like their thing to to torch
car dealerships it would have been the
third it would have been the third one
in two days okay and a lot of these
people
i think car source obviously it's not
like a huge dealership chain like
ford or you know chevrolet or anything
like that
so he went to go defend it but someone a
shot was fired and he defended himself
because
all these people swarmed him well so so
according to the new york times analysis
he got chased he got chased why were
they chasing him they were chasing him
because he had a gun
and number two he was going to defend
what they wanted to burn down
that's what pissed them off tim right
right right it
it pissed them off that they couldn't
burn things that night because they were
armed dudes stopping them the first one
got put out with a fire extinguisher so
they went to car source
they were gonna go torch the dealership
because they thought there was no one
there to defend it
kyle went over there to defend it right
and shots were fired against him
he defended himself the reason why that
all happened
was because these rioters weren't
allowed to commit arson
right that's the context of this entire
story so people that are defending it
like
oh well he defended himself and it's
like these people wanted to commit more
arson
well i mean if the flaming dumpster went
to the gas station they could have blown
it up yes and
killed a bunch of people yes yeah so you
know
these these are interesting trying to
trying to ascertain
and real quick tim real quick after that
first person that got shot right the the
pedo dude right laying on the floor
that's the video that i captured from my
perspective from beginning to end
standing from the corner looking at the
car dealership
that's when they went ballistic and
that's when you see kyle jump on the
phone and i think he says like oh i just
wounded or i just killed something
he says i think i just killed him i
think i just killed someone right or i
think he says i just killed somebody he
was
he was running away at that point when
you see him running away
he wasn't running away to evade police
he wasn't running away
to evade the law or anything like that
he was running away
to turn himself in but rioters started
chasing him with guns
they were gonna execute him okay richie
daily caller
right he's the guy that's over him he
takes his shirt off
right the pedo guy in that moment takes
his shirt off he's trying to help him
like where's the bullet wound where's
the bullet wound no one knew that was in
the head right it wasn't in the head
it wasn't no it no one could really find
it yeah so people thought he got shot in
the head because
he got a graze wound according to so the
medical examiner report says it was a
grazing
yeah the grey's wound is what they were
they were treated but it was a bullet
that bounced around in them and i guess
hit his lung
got it and that's what so they put they
put the shirt on the graze wound on the
head right
that's at the time that's what it looked
like that's why it was gargling yeah
because no one could see it at the time
right
so they they put the shirt on the head
but you can hear the writers in the
video
you can already hear them they're like
did you effing shoot them
yeah what did you do bro and richie's
like no dude i'm trying to help this guy
it wasn't
richie could have got killed yeah yeah
absolutely because they thought it was
him
but then they realized it was kyle and
that's when those dudes started
following him with guns they were gonna
kill him you know but you know you know
why how they figured it out
because he was running that's what they
always tell you when you do when you do
training for rides and stuff
never run never run because then
everyone sees it
and they notice yeah if he just started
walking he's like no no i don't know
yeah then he could have got to the
police but there's actually a video i
don't know if you've seen it
someone's running after him they come up
behind him and they say what's going on
why are you running
and he says i'm getting the police and
then someone behind him you hear them
yell
stop that dude he shot somebody and then
the guy with the camera
it just it all it all goes violent from
that point
so now you've got they were going to
kill him they were going to execute him
that that was a
that was going to be an eye for an eye
situation
did you see uh i mean you got to ask
yourself though so at that point
do the does that dude have the right the
guy that got his his bicep and his
forearm blown off by kyle right
it was just his bicep i'm pretty sure
right yeah at that point does that guy
have the right to walk up to kyle and
shoot him
no you shouldn't because these are
questions you gotta ask
well so for sure and i think it's really
really simple kyle was fleeing towards
the police
and the dude with the glock nine uh the
nine millimeter
tries to go up gun drawn and then ins
you know he he puts his hands up when
kyle lowers up and he runs up and tries
to grab the
the dangerous end of a rifle
and then kyle fires yeah you actually
see
i'm i'm sorry we're gonna get gruesome
you can see the meat of his arm vaporize
on the video just and people have you
can see dude
brutal that kid
he could have killed that guy yeah i
i think he chose not to i think there's
a few things in the situation with kyle
that dramatically different from this
guy
you know rhino in portland for one two
people put their hands up no
it may have actually only been the one
guy puts his hands up and he immediately
lowers the weapon he's like okay i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna shoot somebody
he gets some dude runs over jumps and
then kicks him in the face
in the air and then the other guy with
the skateboard runs over
now a lot of people have said he hit him
over that with a skateboard it i'm not
sure he was doing that so much as trying
to hold him down and grab the rifle and
then he took a bullet into the into the
heart
and that was that was him dying there's
a lot of things that shouldn't have
happened i'll put it this way i'll put
it in contrast
in that situation if kyle wouldn't
have fired i think he would have been
murdered i agree i completely and i was
there
okay i was literally there i was
following it i was documenting it elijah
was like right there
richie was right there i think they'll
agree with me
um if if if he if kyle didn't defend
himself i think they they would have
executed that kid
trump said it and then a couple outlets
said that he was mischaracterizing what
was really happening
facebook's now determined that uh
written house is a mass shooter and you
can't defend him
oh they deleted my video today by the
way they deleted your video yeah which
video
the raw video whoa
today yeah i put it on twitter today
welcome to the nightmare dystopia bro
you got evidence proving what really
went down and they deleted yeah they
scrapped it today i got a notification
this afternoon and they're like uh we
scrapped your video you can't post for
the next 24 hours
you don't you're like uh you know what i
love about these
resistance people they have big tech
oligopolies on their side
they have major tech corporations and
oligarchs defending them
if there ever is going to be an
underground network it's going to be the
journalism you're doing
not the things they're saying this dude
the portland murderer
he gets to go on on prime time vice news
was that show time now i don't know
i don't know where they're airing that i
don't i don't know if they were on hbo i
don't think they are anymore yeah no
they got cancelled from hbo
they get they get to go on to a major
bit multi-billion dollar corporation
and he says blast out my narrative yep
you post evidence facebook nukes it
nukes it dude we're in serious trouble
man
nukes it but let's go deeper oh yeah why
tim
why are they nuking it why because who
who who is affected by these things
the hearer the viewer the voter the
voter
the human so you can't make your own
decision
so you can't make your own conclusion
based off of
the visual evidence what i posted was
evidence like that's being used i'm
positive in an investigation right now
right
that's getting nuked and terminated on
social media
so you can't make a decision right
that's scary that's like it happens
dude i got no idea why i'm still allowed
to be on this platform to be complaining
here i am sitting with you
you're like look i got evidence i was
there i'm a witness here's what really
went down
but but they they demonetize they
destroy they ban
they they they derank all of these other
channels and i'm just lucky enough i
think
i think it's because you know people
don't you know
don't like it i'll say like they're cert
i don't swear and people are like stop
letting them censor you i'm like dude i
don't need to say a swear word if it
means i can have you on the show
telling people the truth yeah i can't
say the name of that guy and don't say
his name
the guy from because i'll delete the
stream the whistleblower dude you say
his name they will shut the stream off
instantly because they have people who
watch
wow yeah they're watching right now no
joke yeah hey guys
i'm just saying hi oh right right yeah
yeah i went back in the early days of
live streaming i actually went to
one company called ustream and they
showed me they had all these computers
and they
had a screen with like i don't know
maybe 50 live streams at once
and they were just sweeping through them
looking for people who would like take
their clothes off
they watch this stuff yeah you say the
wrong thing you're gone
and so i've had people saying to me tim
don't let them sense you just say his
name and if you get banned well you
stood up for what's
right and i'm like and then i can't have
drew on to explain what really happened
imagine
imagine if last year i stood on that i
died on that hill and it's like i will i
refuse
we wouldn't be here right now with you
saying the evidence is being destroyed
facebook is getting rid of it they won't
allow you to defend this guy
and you as a witness said he would have
died if he did not defend himself
and it's it's it's a video of just the
raw
footage there's no commentary it's not
me saying hey this happened this
happened this happened it there's
nothing it's just
the raw video that got terminated today
on facebook on facebook
do you have it on youtube uh i haven't
posted it on youtube yet
you know i'm sure what facebook's
reasoning is gonna be is they're gonna
say it's graphic
yeah but that presents i guess other
issues
are we not allowed i mean but there's
tons of world star videos on facebook
uh you know minorities just busting each
other's faces and bleeding
and knockout game like rage porn right
right and and that's allowed
we're in trouble man right thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you